بعيدًا عن قمرنا وإلى المريخ حيث
كشف علماء من دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة
أمس عن أحدث النتائج التي توصلوا إليها من
مسبار الأمل الإماراتي الذي يدور حول
جار الأرض ويقولون إن لديهم
رؤى جديدة رائدة حول
قمر المريخ على شكل حبة الفول والذي يحوم خلفي
ويسمى ثيموس حصل مسبار الأمل على
أقرب إلى الكواكب من أي مركبة فضائية
منذ عام 1977 وملاحظاتها
تتحدى نظرية قديمة حول
أصول أقمار الكوكب الأحمر
الآن تم تمديد المهمة لمدة
عام آخر تحدثت إلى رئيسة إحدى
وكالة الفضاء الإماراتية سارة الأميري
عنها  العلم وراء كل ذلك وكيف
بدأت هذه الرحلة تحقق من ذلك،
لذلك بدأ كل هذا عندما كنا
نقترب من كوكب المريخ في مارس أه
لنبدأ أه تصوير ديموس حيث تم
التقاط البيانات حول العروض التوضيحية ما تم
اكتشافه هو تكوين
القمر  قريب من تكوين المريخ
بدلاً من أن يكون قريبًا من
تكوين الكويكب الذي تم التقاطه وهو
النظرية الحالية
لأصل أقمار المريخ. لماذا يعد هذا أمرًا
مهمًا
أم ديموس وربما حتى فوبوس يمكن أن
يكون على الأرجح قطعًا من المريخ مشابهة
لـ  قمر الأرض بدلاً من أن يكون
كويكبًا تم التقاطه في مدار حول
المريخ اليوم، ما يهم بالنسبة لنا هو أننا
قمنا بمناورات صغيرة لتغيير
مدار المركبة الفضائية قليلاً،
فنحن قادرون على الاستمرار في التقاط هذه
البيانات في مهمتنا الموسعة والتي
ستستمر  إن
القول بأنني سعيد بهذه
النتائج حتى العام المقبل هو استخفاف تام وأعتقد أنه
بالنسبة للعديد من الأشخاص قد رأينا
الكثير من الاهتمام بالمريخ سواء كان ذلك
خيارًا للجنس البشري في
المستقبل، فلماذا؟  من المهم أن
نفهم المزيد عن
أقماره من حيث فهم ما إذا
كان بإمكانك معرفة البشر المضيفين في مرحلة ما،
لذا فإن مهمتنا العلمية الأساسية هي
في الواقع معالجة ذلك بشكل غير مباشر من
حيث فهم
التغيرات العالمية في مناخ المريخ ونظام الطقس
على المريخ  ونحن
قادرون على التقاط ما يزيد عن 2 تيرابايت
من البيانات حول نظام الطقس على المريخ،
والتقاط العام بأكمله في جميع
الفصول، وبما أن ذلك على وشك الانتهاء،
وكفرصة قدمت نفسها،
وبينما يواصل الفريق العلمي العمل
من أجل حب جمع بيانات إضافية عن
المريخ، بدأنا في جمع البيانات عن
ديموس، وهو كويكب يُفترض أنه تم التقاطه،
وكان هناك سبب آخر
وراء مهمتنا التالية وهو
حزام الكويكبات وكان من
المثير للاهتمام فهم
تركيبات الكويكبات والتقاط
ذلك باستخدام مهمة الإمارات المريخ الآن
النتيجة
اه كانت مفاجئة بطريقة أه إظهار
تركيبة أقرب إلى المريخ من
الكويكب ولكن هذا هو جمال
الاكتشاف العلمي وهذا هو
جمال القيام بعلم غير مسبوق
والتقاط البيانات حول الكواكب فهو
يساعدنا على فهم نظامنا الشمسي
ويساعدنا  أفهم أه الأجسام من حولنا،
نعم بالتأكيد وكما تقول، فأنت تعلم
أنك لم تتوقع أنك ستحصل على
مثل هذه الصورة الجميلة والواضحة
لهذا، لأنه كان لديك وقود إضافي،
لكنني أيضًا أشعر بالفضول بشأن
نواياك.  بالنسبة
للأمل،
ما الذي كنت تعتقد بالفعل أنك
ستحققه،
فيما يتعلق بعلمنا الأساسي؟ إننا
نجري جيدًا في الإجابة على الأسئلة التي
لدينا، سيكون هذا هو
اكتشافنا العلمي المهم الثالث الذي
سيستمر الفريق العلمي في الحصول عليه
البيانات العلمية الفريق اليوم في
مؤتمر دولي مع
علماء آخرين ليسوا في
فريقنا قادرين على الوصول إلى هذه البيانات
من خلال لأول مرة من خلال
مهمة Hope Mars حول المريخ وبينما
نواصل الدراسة واكتشاف
ما هو مهم بالنسبة لنا  هو مواصلة
تقدم العلوم والتكنولوجيا
في دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة النهوض بالصناعة
والاستثمار بشكل أكبر في قطاع الفضاء
والاستثمار بشكل أكبر وإدراك
إمكانات الفضاء التجاري هذا
مجرد شعب واحد من العديد من البرامج
والمشاريع التي تندرج تحت أه
صندوق الإمارات للفضاء الذي  تستمر في تحفيز
التقدم والتطور إلى الأمام،
وهذه المجموعات الصغيرة من الإنجازات
تدفع الفرق إلى الأمام حتى نتمكن من
الاستمرار في تحقيق علوم أفضل وعلوم
عظيمة ليس فقط لدولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة ولكن
لمجتمع الفضاء ككل،
انظر بالتأكيد إلى أن مهمة الإمارات هذه هي
كما تقول  سيتم تمديده لمدة
عام آخر ولكنه الأول لك، إنه
أول مشروع لاستكشاف الكواكب في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
وهو مهم حقًا لدولة
الإمارات العربية المتحدة وفيما يتعلق بما يمكنك
تحقيقه،
أخبرني عن نوع المكالمات الهاتفية التي كنت
تتلقاها من حيث  من
النتائج التي توصلت إليها، كيف تشعر أنت والفريق ومن
الواضح أن السماء هي الحد الأقصى،
لم أعمل مع الفريق
لسنوات، ستكون 10 سنوات، أعتقد أنه
في نهاية هذا العام،
سأدرك فقط إمكانات
المركبة الفضائية و  التأثير والتأثير المضاعف
كان هائلاً هذا
سيكون أسبوعًا مثيرًا للاهتمام أه ليس
فقط بالنسبة للإمارات ولكن بالنسبة للفضاء هذا
قطاع الفضاء الدولي بشكل عام
سيكون لدينا هبوط أول
أم تجاري أه فضاء أه مركبة على
السطح  بالنسبة للقمر، تعتبر هذه التطورات
مهمة ليس فقط بالنسبة إلى الإمارات العربية المتحدة ولكنها
تفتح لنا إمكانات هائلة في الفضاء. وكانت
خطوتنا الأولى التي حفزت
تنشيطًا كبيرًا جدًا هي مهمتنا
إلى المريخ، ولكنها اليوم ليست
المهمة الوحيدة التي قامت بها دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة ولم تعد كذلك.  إنها
الآلية الوحيدة التي نعمل على تطويرها في
تطوير قطاع الفضاء التجاري لدينا،
لذلك أعتقد كفريق أن الإثارة لا
تزال أقل من الواقع
وإدراك إمكانات
المهمة الأولى وتأثيرها على
الاكتشافات العلمية وإعادة كتابة النظريات والتوصل إلى
نظريات جديدة كشيء
غير مسبوق بالنسبة لنا.  نحن